на цьому відео видно як дві повітряні
цілі зникають із радарів
головнокомандувач ЗСУ залужний
підтвердив що Україна знищила російський
військовий літак а50 і підбила іл-22 над
Азовським морем у січні та як військові
повітряних сил змогли це зробити
невідомо РФ втрату не підтверджує а
експерти в Києві схиляються до
використання системи ППО patріotт
виробництва США був це patтріotт чи інша
Західна техніка Україна в цьому випадку
схоже не порушила даної заходу обіцянки
не використовувати його зброю для ударів
по території Росії про те що така
обіцянка існує від початку вторнення РФ
заявляли представники України та
західних країн але в яких документах це
прописано і чи є для цього правові
підстави очевидно що це чутливі питання
як для України так і для заходу відомо
про них мало таких документів у
публічному доступі немає раніше
президент України Володимир Зеленський
та інші особи говорили про домовленості
зі США не використовувати ракетні
системи хамерс на території Росії
повідомлялося також про домовленості
щодо ракет атакамс очевидно що схожі
домовленості існують і між Україною та
іншими країнами проте даних про
формулювання немає опитані ДВ експерти
єдині в думці що може йтися радше про
політичні домовленості бо правову основу
будь-яких запевне України не
використовувати західну зброю на
визнаній території Росії визначити
важко- зазначає британський військовий
аналітик Майкл
Кларк по суті сила їхньої гарантії є
політичною і це дуже потужна політична
гарантія тому що на мій погляд якби
українці застосували західну зброю проти
власне Росії вони б майже одразу
втратили підтримку заходу Не кажучи вже
про те щоб довіряти наративу Путіна про
те що вся ця війна є нападом заходу на
Росію і якщо українці втратять підтримку
заходу то вони фактично програють війну
в тому вигляді в якому вона зараз
є адже тоді захід може перестати давати
зброю Україні або робити це ще
повільніше тож це редше вимушена
політична обіцянка української сторони
ніж документ що зобов'язує юридично до
такої ж думки схиляється й експерт з
міжнародного права Штефан отер потрібно
зазначити що це суто політичне рішення
не застосовувати цю зброю по території
Росії і це рішення не випливає з
міжнародного права тому що Загалом у
разі самооборони зазвичай зрозуміло що
оборонні дії можуть мати місце на
території іншої держави держави агресора
тією мірою як це необхідно для відбиття
нападу інший можливий варіант каже
експерт вписати ці умови до договорів
про постачання
озброєнь у разі сумнівів укладаються
угоди про окремі процеси постачання
оскільки особли у разі складних систем
йдеться не лише про постачання зброї а й
про пакети навчання та технічного
обслуговування для цього вам необхідно
укласти угоди можливо у цих угодах так і
передбачено не нападати на Росію інший
варіант по суті буде політичною
декларацією про те що ви візьмете
системи та не будете використовувати їх
проти Росії у другому випадку це були б
не юридичні зобов'язання а обіцянки Ось
як відповіли на запит ДВ в уряді
Німеччини однієї з провідних
постачальниць зброї Києву у наданих
федеральному урядові запевненнях про
кінцеве місце призначення Україна
зобов'язується не використовувати
отримані з Німеччини товари проти
території іншої держави у порушення
міжнародного права Штефан отер говорить
що такі заяви звичайна частина подібних
договорів і називає формулювання
надзвичайно м'яким за його словами це не
виключає застосування західної зброї на
території РФ оскільки Воно відповідало б
міжнародному
праву для пита про участь у війні зовсім
не має значення чи застосовується зброя
на окупованій Росії території України чи
сусідніх регіонах Росії і те і інше
необхідно для відбиття нападу і є
самообороною згідно зі статтею 51
статуту ООН Україна має право захищатися
у тому числі завдаючи ударів по
території нападника- зазначають експерти
У цій статті за країнами закріплено
право на самооборону якщо від бться
збройний напад захід має право
допомагати Україні зброєю навіть якщо
захист країни вимагатиме атак на
територію агресора - переконані
експерти судова справа проти України
могла б бути лише якби в контракті
якимись чином було прописано що цю зброю
можна використовувати лише за певних
обставин Я не в курсі щоб західні уряди
створили будь-який юридичний договір
вони просто пішли на політичні
запевнення але Навіть якби вони створили
правовий договір цей дого договір на мій
погляд був би менш сильним ніж
обґрунтування статті 51 статуту ООН про
те що Україна має право захищати себе а
зовнішній світ має право допомагати
Україні
захищатися і також ми повинні зауважити
що згідно з цією статтею також західні
лідери або західні столиці західні
держави чи інші можуть використовувати
свою власну зброю щоб поцілити по
військових об'єктах агресора бо вважають
що вони повністю солідарні з Україною
безумовно вони вважають що є якісь
червоні лінії які ніхто не визначив які
юридично не мають сенсу що це своєрідне
обмеження яке Росія не терпітиме але для
мене це повний абсурд перш за все тому
що це по суті шантаж з боку
Росії іншими словами удар по Росії
західною зброєю не був би порушенням
статуту ООН але західні країни цього не
хочуть
чому наратив Путіна - це старий наратив
про Другу світову війну що він
намагається захистити Росію від фаши
вторгнення ми знаємо що це не так але
будь-які напади на Росію допомагають
йому висунути цей фальшивий аргумент
своєму власному народу Я думаю що
обережність яка існує на заході в цьому
питанні обумовлена імперативом
стримування конфлікту ніхто на заході не
хоче щоб це стало конфліктом західної
Європи та США проти Росії і саме з цієї
причини ідея не атакувати Росію напряму
є дуже чіткою лінією яку НАТО
намагається провести і підтримує
протягом двох років і я думаю що буде
підтримувати Протягом наступних двох
років бажання не допустити цього
призвело до того що західні країни не
лише не постачають Україні певних видів
зброї а й обмежують радіус дії
поставленої- каже французький політолог
Ніколя
тензер ви знаєте що всі ракети великої
дальності передані зараз Україні мали
обмежений радіус дії наприклад
французькі ракети я маю на увазі скальп
могли нормально досягати цілі за 450 км
наскільки я пам'ятаю зараз їх обмежено у
дальності 250 км Чи десь так так само і
для американських атакамс ці конкретні
атакамс дальньої дії були обмежені 195
км замість 300 це також означає що
враховуючи положення пускових установок
цих ракет вони поки що просто не можуть
досягти російської території вони можуть
дістати до Криму що добре Але Крим
Звичайно є українською
територією це не території Росії але
вдарити навіть по білгороду буде дуже
важко Не кажучи вже про Москву чи Сибір
у січні бундестаг не підтримав
пропозицію передати далекобійні ракети
Таурус для ЗСУ Це одні з найсучасніших
крилатих ракет повітряного базування що
є на озброєнні німецьких
військово-повітряних сил Вони мають
радіус дії 500 км і можуть знищувати
добре захищені цілі приміром бункерні
системи чому Німеччина відмовляється
передати Києву крилаті ракети тарус
подібні за своїми характеристиками до
британських та французьких ракет чи
пов'язано це з ядерним статусом Лондона
та Парижа тензер вважає що це може бути
одним із факторів але більш вірогідною
причиною він називає те що Таурус можуть
бути більш ефективними ніж scalp та
британський Storm
Shadow німецький уряд прекрасно розуміє
що Таурус ймовірно ефективніший за
скальб і сторм
або навіть атакамс тому що це чудова
зброя Вона може зруйнувати бункери або
дуже важку інфраструктуру і може бути
використана проти керченського мосту це
безумовно буде дуже корисно для
українців тому що Крим є одним із
ключових стратегічних об'єктів для
України у цьому з ним погоджується і
Майкл Кларк українцям потрібні ракети
Таурус ракети Таурус можуть знести
Керченський міст і на мій погляд це
перше що вони повинні зробити вони могли
б зробити багато інших корисних речей а
але на мій погляд це найкраще що Україна
могла б зробити в перші місяці 2024 року
щоб повернути Терези на користь України
тому що наразі баланс віддаляється від
України баланс рухається в бік Путіна з
різних причин руйнування мосту який веде
з Росії до Криму за його словами було б
у рамках міжнародного права оскільки
збудували його
нелегально юридично він там не повинен
бути Він виник внаслідок незаконного
завоювання та незаконної агресії і якби
росіяни звернулися так би мовити до
Організації Об'єднаних Націй або до
міжнародного права щодо руйнування мосту
я можу вам гарантувати що вони нікуди не
дійдуть тому що міст сам по собі є
незаконним
будівництвом чи з'являться у Росії
підстави звинувачувати Захід у тому що
він став стороною конфлікту якщо Україна
вдарить по її території західною зброєю
Штефан отер упевнений що їх немає адже
постачання озброєнь не не робить країни
заходу стороною конфлікту у сьогоднішніх
умовах скасування західних обмежень
виглядає малоймовірним І хоча ці
обмеження мають політичний характер вони
серйозно стримують
Україну наслідки можуть бути лише
політичними якщо Україна скористається
наданою зброєю не так як ми це розуміємо
це призведе до зловживання довірою і
може призвести і до того що постачання
зброї в тому ж обсязі що і раніше вже не
здійснювати
подати до суду на іншу державу не так
просто механізм який підтримує таку
домовленість є швидше політичним
механізмом але що буде якщо Росія
досягне успіху на фронті і під загрозою
опиниться існування України Про що прямо
заявляє Володимир
Путін Навіть якби Україні загрожувало
зникнення Я думаю що пряма Атака по
Росії все одно була би проблемою я
сумніваюся що західні країни на це однак
якщо на куну буде виживання України
існує ймовірність того що західні
військово-повітряні сили могли б
становити безпольотну зону над Україною
це означає що на російські військові
повітряні цілі може бути націлено зброю
країн НАТО що діє з території
[музика]
України